parler inaugure bus délégué de la
chambre de commerce franco turc est avec
nous sur ce plateau et d'induire bus
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
est ce que cette tournée de richie
tayyip erdogan est bénéfique
économiquement pour la turquie
quelques accords majeurs ont été conclus
finalement alors l'histoire entre la
turquie et l'afrique ne remonte pas à
l'actualité de 2020 en fait il ya eu un
déclic
courant 2008 à l'époque de la crise
financière la turquie a eu des
difficultés comme tous les autres pays
et là à l'époque le président erdogan
avait pris l'addition de prendre son
bâton de pèlerin et d'aller nouer des
accords à l'étranger notamment en
afrique afin de mettre en place des
accords de libre échange
donc depuis cette période c'est à dire
au cours de ces dix douze dernières
années les accords de coopération
politique culturelle est aussi
économique se densifie donc ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui est en fait la
continuité d'un travail de fond
de la part de nature qu'elle est très
concrètement les avantages d'investir au
sénégal par exemple quelle est la
stratégie du président turc alors les
turcs ont un fort besoin d'expansion
économique la turquie aujourd'hui c'est
la seizième puissance mondiale et à une
volonté de se développer notamment sur
le continent africain
par exemple dans le secteur du btp il
s'avère que les sociétés lecture font
partie du top 4 mondial donc des turcs
ont tout intérêt à aller vers des pays
qui ont un besoin de construction
notamment le sénégal afin pourquoi pas
de conte sur les routes des
infrastructures des bâtiments publics
des avants des aéroports notamment
l'aéroport du caire il ya une quinzaine
d'années parce qu'on les turcs qui ont
construit
quelle relation y at-il entre ces pays
africains justement et le président turc
ce sont des bonnes relations ce sont des
relations solides sur vous alors la
turquie bénéficie d'un réseau consulaire
à travers le monde
l'un des plus développés et donc il ya
un lien physique présent dans chacun des
pays surtout en afrique et le président
r douanes ne cessent d'intensifier ses
relations par rapport par exemple avec
l'algérie ils sont en train de mettre en
place un conseil de coopération
ils sont en train de mettre en place un
partenariat pour la construction d'une
usine de pétrochimie en turquie avec une
société algérienne des turcs
actuellement remporté des appels
d'offres dans le bac dans le btp que ce
soit au maroc en algérie en afrique
noire
par exemple au maroc sont les turcs qui
ont construit des lignes ferroviaires
les lignes de métro de tramways etc
donc au final on ne le voit pas mais
actuellement les turcs sont très actives
sur deux salles africain vous le disiez
un la turquie c'est le 13e pays au monde
un l'économie turque en tout cas la 13e
au monde est-ce que erdogan cherche
finalement à gagner des places à devenir
une force économique majeur pour peser
davantage alors selon les statistiques
on est plus vers la 15ème 16ème 16e
place donc ça veut dire quoi ça jacques
à chaque pas que le g20 se réunit la
turquie en fait partie la turquie joue
dans le concert des nations
et forcément la turquie est un projet
ambitieux et volontariste notamment pour
2023 pour fêter le centenaire de la
république turque
la volonté de la turquie c'est de
rentrer dans le top 10 mondial et pour
ce faire il ne cesse
d'engager des projets de développement
notamment économiques au cours de ces
quatre dernières semaines tout
simplement la turquie vient de lancer
une marque automobile
donc la turquie et deux nuls
constructeur automobile ils veulent
lancer la première voiture 100 %
fabriquée en turquie ce qui est plutôt
innovant en parallèle ils sont aussi
innover dans le secteur militaire ils
viennent de construire leur premier sous
marin avec la russie ils ont mis en
place un accord de gazoducs afin
d'approvisionner l'europe
donc au niveau économique la turquie a
des ambitions et ne cesse de multiplier
les projets alors on sait la turquie qui
intervient aujourd'hui en libye est ce
que cette intervention selon vous ne
pourrez pas écorner l'image de la
turquie en afrique alors la limite à un
cas particulier il s'avère qu'en
méditerranée au sud de la turquie des
réserves d'hydrocarbures vient d'être
découvert et il ya un consortium qui a
été mis en place notamment entre la
france chypre grèce israël la turquie a
voulu sa part du gâteau
ne serait ce que dans le projet de
forage mais aussi en termes de revenus
la turquie a été exclu du jeu et donc
pour ce faire la turquie a contre
attaqué en mettant en place un
partenariat avec la libye notamment le
pouvoir en place le gène à qui reconnu
par la communauté internationale et à
travers cet accord là la turquie a
déployé des soldats sur le sol libyen
afin de défendre le pouvoir en place
merci beaucoup une amie russe d'avoir
partagé votre analyse sur notre plateau
je rappelle que vous êtes délégué de la
chambre de commerce franco turque